waking up every day with each it's like
me asking you questions here we go we're
going to be in 20 seconds night
I think TV debates are a great thing and
I look forward to taking part very good
and you know when I think talking about
others and I think would make it really
fun
Nigel Faraj what do you think well it'll
be others for I think basically these
debates should be about people have a
prospect of becoming Prime Minister tell
me
practically you're the man that sorts
like the Benz you're the man that sorts
like the parking you're Eric Pickles
tell me straight what you're going to do
with these families it's very
straightforward you have no idea about
funding you have no idea about staffing
you have no idea about resources that's
what's coming up do you see yourself as
Santa Claus or the Grinch you all give
with one hand but you take with the
other you're all sneaky wiki and you
just can't say it straight you're not
gonna tell me the bad bits I just I've
just tried to do my job and ask them but
you are naughty and you are mischievous
as a Chancellor and you know you are a
fling gimmick not on the subject of
flailing gimmicks would this be one by
any chance
Fergie always said he had to make it
clear there was one boss he was the boss
that was it
that's not your sort of way of doing
things though my way of doing things
because it's politics it's community its
people its government is actually if I
may say so not the same as managing a
football it's always into a competition
so if you want to go your winner if you
wanna be a winner go to I wanted to win
do you want to beat do you want to be
Prime Minister can you do you want to
win the league plays do you want yes
your Labor's doing very well yes we are
gonna win and the goons lane for a
pleasure awesome or or do you want to
win which means that you probably don't
think it look like we doing what you run
over there summer so somebody was
reversing behind you there you're
kissing action when it came to the
finale
the big curtain call at the end of the
stage yesterday there was a slightly if
you don't might be saying some I think
you may need some lessons in this some
choreography and involved and I would
just like to illustrate my point with
this clip this is the beautiful Justine
your wife here you
for the killer here see the clip well
well you know what happened you went in
for the kill there straight away and she
was having none of it was it a bad
breath problem what what what what
exactly was the problem here look what I
can say she's never complained is this
she going to the European Convention on
Human Rights I'm sorry to hear that
you're moving on I've you've interviewed
me not just in working for sky but where
you were previously and I wish you all
the very best for the future
you're very kind and I'm sorry you're so
devastated at me moving on Prime
Minister thank you
you'll get over it